Carroll is on Facebook Dave I'm thinking
about telling my selling my timeshare
where do I start
well Carol I got really bad news you got
screwed there's no place to sell a
timeshare you can't give the dadgum
things away
look your timeshare up on eBay they're
selling them for a dollar the people
sold for a dollar what would they do
that because they want to get rid of the
fees the annual freaking fees and that's
what you're that's why you everything
about selling it and and or you owe
money on it god help you so I I have
looked at numerous ways over the years
of doing the show to get people out of
time shares and I never could find
anything until I found this company
called timeshare exit team about three
years ago we started endorsing them and
I've had so much fun pissing off the
timeshare people because Tom's your exit
team will get you out of their timeshare
now you're gonna pay the money to do
that that's what they do and they charge
you upfront and they give your money
back guarantee if they don't get you out
but they'll get you out they'll get you
out of your timeshare you're just stuck
there they're worth nothing they have no
value there is no market for them
there's a 99% dissatisfaction with the
industry
this is pretty much sucks beyond belief
and on top of that there's several these
people selling these things that tell
people in their presentation that Dave
Ramsey bought one from them which is
about as dumb as saying Dave Ramsey has
a credit card that's ridiculous
time share exit team do not talk to
anybody else these guys are the best at
getting you out time's your exit team
this is the Dave Ramsey show